こんにちははじめ社長です
はいという気で
動画のタイトルにもある通り私はじめ冊を
アメリカに3年間留学に行ってきます
えっとまず言わなきゃいけないことが a というのがとても遅くなって
そして急になってしまいとても申し訳ないです
実はですね結構ギリギリでもうアメリカに行く寸前ぐらいです今
えーっと大変いうのが遅くなって申し訳なかったです
こうやっぱあっと言いたかったですよ急に僕ですかね
たぶん僕の岡田をアメリカで言う時の事を知ってる人はめちゃくちゃ少ないです
本当に見えつの友達とかにしか入ってないんで受注バーでも知ってるたほぼいない
ぐらいじゃないのかな
本当に急になって申し訳ないですまあ3年間ほどアメリカに留学に行くわけなんです
けども
ちょっと2つ
目的があります一つは
英語力のアップを担当し嫌いですね大学生の時にイギリスに留学してたんですけども
判断しだというかに英語を聞くのはよくなったんですけど話すのはやっぱあんまり
変わらなくてなぜまぁ今回3年間みっちりとねちゃんと英語を勉強して英語しっかり
喋れるようになってやっていきたいと思っております
二つ目が
僕の将来のことなんですけど映像関係の勉強をしたいと思っておりましてアメリカの
そういった学校の方に3年間に宮廷ですまあ今 youtube をしているわけなん
ですけれども
正直ちょっと
もっといろんなことができるんじゃないかと思って体
youtube でね youtube 意外と思う youtube 以外でもなん
ですけども
深今後映像系のことをやっていきたいと思っているので
まあ自分のスキルアップのためにもねアメリカに行って映像技術の最先端を学んでいき
たいなと思っております
大学卒業してからほんとすぐ行きたかったんですアメリカにマーケットちょっと
いろいろね
磯
が叱ったりして予定がかさばってて今のタイミングになっちゃったんですけどもかなり
前から行こうと思っていましたアメリカ
絶対でも通常言ってたんで多分わかる人にはわかると思うんですけど僕の中では大きな
夢の一つ同時期今の生活もすごい言うんですよ
日本での生活毎日結構忙しいんですけどそれでも
楽しく youtube をやってて正直も文句言うところがないくらい今すごい幸せ
な生活をしていると思ってるんですけど
現像で満足すると
そこでも同じだと思ったんで今を見るより未来のことを見据えてね
学今後行動してみたいなと思ってるんで今後僕がもっと大きな
男になるためには
このタイミングでアメリカに3年間いくべきだなっていうか思いました
何いえばいいかわかんねーんだなぁこういう感じの時に言えばイングロ
まあひとまず本当に急になったのはとても申し訳なかったとこの家なんですけどもまぁ
アメリカに3年間いくって言ってもそんなでもずっと向こうにいる感じではないんです
よの3年間ずっとアメリカにいるっていう
て河内町も結構日本に帰ってくるのでそうした時に泊まる場所がまた
転々としてるんでこの位は書いたままで日本に帰ってきた時にまた普通に停まります
そんな感じかな
イギリスの留学つんにわかったんですけど留学ちゃって時間が止まった感じに感じるん
ですよ僕はね僕はイギリスで半年か入学してた時にすごい
いろんなことを考える機会になれたんですよそこでエコーいろいろ考えたり今後どうし
ようって考えた結果
youtube になろうという決断ができたって所もあって i
リスのあの半年間の留学がなかったらまあ今の始めたといなかったです
留学とかね海外です長い期間過ごしたりに修行っていうのかな
わかんないんですけどそういう期間ですごい人生の中では大事な器官だと思ってるんで
僕はアメリカでの3年間は2にはしたくないと思っておりますっ
高校頻道毎日とはいかないかもしれませんが
頑張って動画豊泉しようと思ってますんではじめシャツアメリカ編のスタートですね俺
は
なんでこんなこういうこと言いたくないんですけど
俺は日本だけで止まるつもりはないんでもっともっと上を目指していっ
現状に満足せず
もっとすごいことやってみたいなと思っていますあそうなあの僕の炎アメリカ留学相談
生た身内の友達からなんかさっきサプライズで動画が届いたんでちょっと見てみ
ましょう
めちゃーん
秋ぐらいから
おおーー
いきたいっていうのは派
ハーン
ん
嬉しいですね
でも
ん
身近な
友達として動か持ってるねー
なんというか3年間めんちゃんが日本にいないっていうのがいい
ストーン
流れもになるん
って今から大活躍してー
でまたん
海外で日本以上に活躍してくれたらな
することをお
しています
はい
寂しいけど
頑張ってしてください海外でもを走っ
8僕は本当にうれしいです
じゃめちゃもいらっしゃいん
ちょっと一さん3年間
ろすねー
いうことを
その勉強するということで
3日に行ってしまう
ても寂しいです
ヘッド僕が
大学愛知愛の時からな
今年デー
午前目
んと一緒に動画をやって
いろいろ遊びに行ったりとかもたくさんしてたんで
まあ3年間いい
すごい
外しまってなかなか
会えない中華ほぼ会えなくなっちゃうと思う
アロすっいろいろ勉強してい
まあ帰ってきた時に
もっと
とそれ
の高い動画を作ったり
世界で活躍できる
一番いいです
てほしいなあと
ありがとうか本当に頑張ってくださいはい
惠山
持っています
はぁ
5番ハゲピザ3
how i 付き合いの部やは
本町を風邪ひいてて散歩のタイミングでまじかへん床屋が変ですね
感は出るして生揚げですよくわかんない状況を出すかも明かしその通りなんだろ
今日はじめに
のん
月曜聞いた応援のメッセージを取ることにしました
モデルとうそれが卒業する時柱は自分にメッセージショップの葉
今日ははじめに1コメッセージを伝えたいと思います
頑張ってん
いや遠いけど応援してます
でっ帰ってきたらまたう
それがそう
じゃあ
モデルと友達との別れとがも辛いんですけども
僕は悲しみよりその時期今後の楽しみの方が大きいです
もっともっと大きくなって
胸を張って
日本に帰ってくれる表
楽しみにしています
じゃじゃーん
b